what advice would you have for someone
wanting to become an editor possibly
can't afford college maybe they would
just learn from watching YouTube videos
which I know there's a plethora of
information from children online that
you could just learn all sorts of
interesting little techniques where
would you suggest someone start and how
can they actually get in the business
and start either interning or working
that is a good question and it's a
tricky one to answer I mean obviously
the obviously they have like you learn
by doing so edit everything you can when
I when I was in film school and I
decided that editing was what I wanted
to go into I made it a point to tell all
my friends that that I want to be an
editor this is what interests me the
most and I am and and so I started
working with their films and editing
editing as many films as I could when I
then made my way up the ranks as an
assistant working for Sally Mickey for
example she would give me scenes in in
like the movie all the pretty horses
that Billy Bob Thornton directed she
gave me some scenes to cut and it was
great that I like I would I would do the
work and I would send it off to her and
she would evaluate it and call me and
tell me this I was on location in San
Antonio while she was in LA and she
would give me her thoughts on on the
work that I'd done and and tell me what
she had done to it and why she white the
changes that she had made and why she
and why she made them and it was very
inspiring to me it kept me going it it's
something that now that I'm in the
editors chair I try to do with my
assistants because I think there's no
question that it contributed to me
getting where I am in terms of how to
break into the business everybody goes
down a different path I can say without
question that I've worked with a lot of
people who didn't go to college so going
to film school is not necessarily
something that you need to have done but
but I found it very helpful because I I
established relationships with my
classmates that led directly it's
me finding work but you know when I was
just first starting out in Los Angeles
the way people would try to find work in
editorial if they didn't know anyone
literally you you there would be
facilities there are facilities that are
primarily editing houses and you would
just you'd walk around with a stack of
resumes and you'd knock on every door
and you'd see if someone would allow you
to talk to them for like 15 minutes in
hand a resume and maybe they would end
up needing someone at some point down
the line and that could lead to work
sometimes it did usually usually what
happened to me is that I was introduced
to one person in this industry a guy
named Bob Layton who was Rob Reiner as
editor I'd worked with a friend of his
when I was in New York and Bob
introduced me to his assistants and they
in turn made some introductions and and
and through that I managed to get my
first internship and as luck would have
it one of the people I worked with on
that internship got a job working on a
movie that was paying and and she asked
me to come aboard and help out as an
apprentice editor and that got me into
the Union and once I was in the Union I
became eligible for a lot more work and
through those same connections IIIi was
able to land my first Union job on the
picture Boogie Nights so but you know
everyone's path is different sure last
question just okay lastly why editing
when you were in film school why not be
the the DP why not why not screenwriting
why editing so everyone goes to film
school to become a director and I had
this realization about midway through my
my sophomore year at film school that
god there are a lot of really talented
people in my class and the idea that all
of us are going to get directing gigs
immediately upon graduation this is a
little ridiculous so so perhaps I should
focus on a craft just in case this
directing thing doesn't work out and an
editing was always my favorite part of
the process because I feel it's the
closest to directing
you are you're you're telling the story
visually you are crafting the
performances you and you're doing it
from the comfort of an air-conditioned
room and interestingly enough at the
time when I made the decision editing
was the the part of the process that
required the least technical know-how
because we were like I learned how to
edit on film
we're using a steam back a flatbed
editing system all you need to know was
how to thread it up and you could be an
editor being a cinematographer you had
to understand lighting and you had to
understand taking taking light meter
readings and film stocks you had to know
all of this stuff editing was really
just all about the art and it really
appealed to me and eyes that's what I
focused on and it's been very good to me